So over the last couple of days, we've spent
some time going through the really shocking
revelations that are made in Bob Woodward's
new book, Rage, including, of course, that
Donald Trump all the way back in February
knew the seriousness of Corona virus, downplayed
it publicly for political reasons, even though
he clearly knew.
And now 200000 people nearly have died.
And that is shocking.
It's not an exaggeration to say that is a
shock.
It is shocking that anybody would do that.
Any human would do that regardless of their
motivations or their position.
But our friend and he is our friend, he's
been on the show a couple of times.
Steve Almond wrote a really good commentary
for WB You Are, which we are linking to.
You can also check out my interviews with
Steve Almond.
He wrote a really good op ed where he makes
the case that as ridiculous as as Donald Trump's
actions are as shocking and outrageous and
immoral as it is that Donald Trump.
Didn't just deceive about coronavirus, I mean,
he straight up lied, knowingly lied.
He didn't just get it wrong, he lied.
The real thing we should be horrified about.
Is that it won't matter.
And I actually agree with Steve Almond.
I've given this a lot of thought over the
last 24 hours.
And yes, Donald Trump publicly said the virus
is under control.
We shut it down.
It's going to go away like a miracle.
15 cases will soon be zero.
All of it privately.
He knew how serious it was.
He believed that it was so contagious.
In early February that it was spreading through
the air.
And he said it to Bob Woodward.
And it's insane.
But as Steve Almond points out, the shock
is that Trump's support will likely not move
as a result.
This story will rage for some period of time,
just like early last week, early this week,
late last week, rather, the troops are losers
and suckers.
Story was raging just like the Ukraine story
did.
Just like every story.
And then something else will happen and things
will move on.
And Donald Trump's approval will keep bouncing
between 39 and 47 percent.
And ultimately, this election is going to
come down to not the country realizes, wow,
this is bad.
Hey, we're a laughing stock.
Hey, this is a joke.
We have to stop this.
This election, in the end, is going to come
down to can our turnout outdo their voter
suppression?
That is ultimately what this will be about.
And if you want any proof of this, simply
spend some time checking out the posts over
the last 48 hours in the typical pro Trump
on conclave's of the Internet.
And what you will find is that over the last
48 hours, as the story exploded, first of
all, for the most part, the Trump is just
ignored it.
They pretend the story doesn't exist.
And then when it does come up, they either
say it's fake news or they assail someone's
character like Bob Woodward.
In this case, they will protect Trump at all
costs.
The less involved ones will simply experience
cognitive dissonance and say it can't possibly
be real.
And almost every day it seems, certainly every
week there is a bombshell that would end other
presidencies.
It would they would have ended other presidencies.
And I said this yesterday, and I think it
bears repeating, if the world really made
sense.
Trump never would have been elected.
Wouldn't be possible.
The public wouldn't be so stupid as to do
it.
But it happened.
If the world made a little more sense than
it does, Trump would have had to resign by
now.
But instead, Trump has a shot at four more
years.
He really does.
And the Republican Party, including Mitch
McConnell and friends McConnell and friends,
Mitch and friends, allowed this to happen.
They could have intervened.
They could have removed Trump.
They could have voted to convict on impeachment.
They could have done any number of things.
But they are also complicit and they need
to be punished as well.
And hopefully some of them will be punished
by losing Martha McSally for one and others.
But later, their punishment should come as
well.
I keep thinking back to that speaker, that
woman at the DNC who spoke about her father,
who died of coronavirus, who believed Trump
that it wasn't really serious.
And she said, you know, it's kind of a cliche
line, but it but it is powerful in a sense
as well.
She said her father's only preexisting condition
before he died, before he got rotavirus, was
that he trusted Donald Trump.
And meanwhile, Donald Trump has run counter
propaganda.
We talked yesterday how now Donald Trump has
been nominated by some far right Norwegian
politician for a Nobel Peace Prize, if you
can imagine something more outrageous.
And he's been retweeting that and running
a counter narrative for a second step back.
Come with me on this thought experiment, step
back.
Imagine the worst thing Trump could possibly
do.
Look at what?
And what could it be?
And then how would his base react?
And you will realize that this Bob Woodward
fiasco is unlikely to have a huge impact.
Imagine an audiotape of Trump Trump screaming
the N-word.
Imagine a video of him with Putin talking
about a quid pro quo to win the election.
Imagine a video of Trump committing sexual
assault or Trump's taxes come out.
And it turns out, yeah, he's cheating on his
taxes.
I still don't think it would matter to a large
portion of his base.
Maybe maybe if Trump was on video saying the
people who voted me, they're suckers and idiots,
I wouldn't be caught dead with them.
I don't even like them at my clubs.
Maybe that would make an impact.
And I'm not even sure.
I think even in that case, if Trump just straight
up insulted his followers, which he's done
indirectly, but if he did it more directly,
I think most of them still say, you know,
I don't need Trump to like me.
I just need him to make America great.
And by the way, I'm sure he was talking about
somebody else, not me specifically.
He wasn't talking about followers like me.
He was talking about supporters like some
other people, even in that case.
I struggle to see how it really affects Donald
Trump's approval.
So check out Steve Oltmanns piece on WB.
You are.
We're linking to it about this.
I think Steve is right.
I think the real tragedy is that this isn't
going to hurt Trump in any kind of substantive
way.